Vous allez devenir la plus grande icône commerciale des circuits!
Allez le 95! Wouhou!!!
Films, publicités, parrainages de produits!
Kachow!!!
Vous pensiez être déjà célèbre?
Nous serons fabuleusement riches!
Qu'est-ce que vous essayez de me dire, Monsieur?
Vous ne courrez pas cette saison...
Chaque fois que vous perdez...
Vous vous faites du tort.
Je suis navré...
Votre carrière... arrive à son terme...
On ne peut espérer qu'une chose :
c'est que cette course ne soit pas sa dernière.
C'est moi qui déciderai quand j'arrêterai.
Comment tu te sens?
Je peux pas retourner sur les circuits et recommencer comme avant, ça ne marchera plus.
On peut pas aller contre le progrès.
Tu sais ce que je ferais moi?
Quoi?
J'sais pas. J'ai rien trouvé.
J'suis trop contente de vous entraîner!
J'adore les défis!
D'ailleurs, je vous ai baptisé : Mon projet senior!
A vos marques!
Prêts? Partez!
Wow wow wow wow!
La plage m'a avalée...
Jackson Storm a établi un nouveau record aujourd'hui!
En enregistrant le meilleur temps jamais réalisé!
Vous êtes au courant du record que Storm vient de battre?
Vous envisagez de prendre votre retraitre?
C'est ma dernière chance, Cruz! La dernière!
Si je suis battu, aucun sponsor ne voudra m'engager!
N'ayez pas peur de l'échec!
Ne partez pas battu d'avance, vous avez votre chance!
Quand je vous regardais à la télé, on aurait dit que vous voliez! Que vous n'aviez peur de rien!
J'aurai voulu connaître cette sensation...
FLASH MCQUEEEEEEEEENN!!!!!
Tu seras jamais aussi rapide que Storm,
mais tu peux être plus malin que lui!
Je ne connais que la course comme récompense.
Le reste, je m'en fiche.
La probabilité d'une victoire de Storm est de 95,2%.
Allez McQueen!